merci de nous rejoindre sur TVfil
nouvelle édition du 78 sport 26 minutes
pour faire le point complet sur
l'actualité sportive locale dans le
département des evvelines bonsoir
Anthony bonsoir Wilfried au menu de ce
78 sport du handbal Montini a joué son
dernier match de championnat ce weekend
et termine à la 5e place de sa poule de
National 2 nous ferons le bilan de cette
saison avec la capitaine Gabrielle
parloer mais tout d'abord nous allons
parler de sport solidaire et du tibreak
un tournoi de golf caritatif au profit
de l'association SS gazelle et la
présidente de l'association et
organisatrice de l'événement est avec
nous bonsoir Véronique Chapelin et vous
êtes très bien accompagné on a envie de
dire puisque Hassan endam exchampion du
monde WBO est parmi nous bonsoir à vous
bonsoir alors a que son imposante
ceinture voilà exactement exactement la
très belle ceinture que que vous avez pu
conserver après après le combat alors
alors quel est le concept de ce de ce
tyreak un nom qui qui interpelle un
petit peu al le tibreak d'abord existe
depuis 21 ans 1992 il rassemble des
sportifs de haut niveau de disciplines
différentes c'est ça l'objectif c'est
que des sports de tous horizons soient
présents et l'objectif c'est que ces
sportifs sont là pour tous la même cause
les enfants nous finançons des centres
sur le thème sport éducation et santé
des enfants et donc les sportifs sont là
non seulement bénévolement aux
événements on récolte des fonds mais
ensuite il y a un suivi c'est pérenes
puisqu'ils sont parins et marenes des
centres que nous finançons ils suivent
les enfants quasiment au quotidien et
voilà alors cette 21e édition donc se
passe du côté du château de la couardne
avec le golf de l'accue des Yvelines
comment vous faites pour attirer autant
de champions là il y a 50 champions à
peu près qui vont venir de toute
discipline confondu et des palmarases
incroyables c'est c'est dur ou pas de de
les attirer sur un parcours de golf oui
c'est c'est difficile parce que parce
qu'ils ont des plannings très chargés
ils sont hyper sollicités de par leur
carrière à leurs sponsors mais je dirais
que ce qui paye c'est la fidélité et le
temps ça fait moi moi-même je travaille
chez Nike je suis sportive ça fait 20
ans qu'on qu'on se suit tout au long de
l'année et ce sont des gens qui sont là
par fidélité surtout ils ont vu sur le
terrain ce qu'on avait réalisé donc ça
leur donne envie de continuer et puis il
se retrouvent entre eux il y a il y a un
respect des sportifs les uns envers les
autres et puis puis également je pense
qu'il y a un esprit de bonne humeur de
convivialité je pense que dans un monde
difficile une année de trêve comme ça où
on est sûr de venir pour la bonne cause
et faire la fête voilà mais c'est
difficile et on a un panel de 500
champions et tous ne sont pas égaux sur
le terrain parce qu'ils sont pas
forcément tous amateurs pratiquant
régulier de golf il y en a qui arrivent
en disant moi je ne jouerai pas au golf
je déteste le golf 2 ans justement on va
poser la question votre Casan justement
le golf c'est quelque chose que vous
pratiquez un petit peu ou pas j'ai
jamais joué au golf ce jour pr et je
suis prêt à pratiquer pour la bonne
cause donc voilà ça devrait aller pour
envoyer la balle très très loin pu' pas
trop comment vous êtes venu justement à
ce à ce te break qu'est-ce qui vous a
motivé à venir en aide à cette
association déjà la-base j'ai connu
Véronique par un très bon ami à moi qui
est un grand frère Patrick Mboma qui
fait partie de l'association donc à
partir du moment où je j'ai vu que c'est
il y avait des belles choses et que
c'était pour la bonne cause donc j'ai
j'ai tout de suite adhéré au projet et
j'ai dit je vais vous suivre et
aujourd'hui je suis là tout le temps et
toutes les réunions et donc je suis à
fond SOS gazelle donc le le 21 mai
prochain donc il y aura il y aura ce
tournoi mais à côté de ça il y aura
plein d'ateliers pour pour découvrir
d'autres activités pour les enfants
voilà il il y a deux ACS parallèle il y
a cette fameuse compétition de golf qui
li a Roland Garros avec un titre
honorifique de champion des champions
qui a été gagné par Noa l'année dernière
et en parallèle il y a 5 ateliers avec
200 enfants qui sont encadrés par les
sportifs en activité qui eux ne jouent
pas au golf il y aura de l'athlétisme du
rugby du cart du basket la box du foot
et bien sûr il y a un ring de boxe avec
quatre grands champions don Assad et
justement sur ce sur cet atelier de box
Assan quel est le message que vous allez
avoir envie de donner à ces enfants
c'est le même message que j'ai appris
quand j'ai commencé la boxe tout petit à
6 ans c'est-à-dire que ce sera vraiment
une initiation la boxe parce que la boxe
c'est comme on dit c'est un noblard ça
nous apprend ça nous donne une hygiène
de vie une ligne de conduite
exemplaire la règle numéro une de la
boxe c'est c'est la discipline alors
c'est ce qu'on essaiera d'apprendre aux
enfant d'une autre manière et en même
temps le montrer que la box c'est un jeu
de cache-cache comme on fait sur HRY
c'est toucher sans se faire toucher tout
simplement c'est pas faire mal c'est pas
brutal et puis voilà ce sera vraiment le
message à faire passer aux enfants et
alors sur ce tournois de de golf les
sportifs qui ont été tous de haut niveau
qui sont encore il y a quand même ce
petit challenge ce titre comme vous
l'avez dit de de champion des champions
ça doit vous intéresser un petit peu ça
quand même àan non bien sûr si je suis
un gagneur je suis un compétiteur et
donc voilà forcément c'est comme dans la
vie c'est comme partout je serai là pour
gagner le titre de champion des
champions devant tous ces champions qui
seront là que je respecte bien et on
sera tous là pour la même cause au même
niveau et donc ce jour-là je voudrais ê
le champion des champions allez chercher
le titre point vous allez chercher le
titre au point voilà s'il le faut il y
aura pas beaucoup de R et c'est un
tournoi en plus qui permet de récolter
beaucoup de fonds l'année dernière vous
aviez récolté à peu près 50000 € euh où
vont bah voilà où va tout cet argent
derrière vous vous donnerz pour du
matériel pour des pour des centres
scolaires tout à fait alors c'est
l'objectif principal finalement au bout
du compte il y a la fête mais on récolte
des fonds euh nous créons des centres
euh pour accueillir les enfants sur le
thème sport éducation et santé et nous
finançons d'autres centres au Sénégal en
au Cameroun en France et également du
matériel scolaire du matériel sportif et
des médicaments voilà alors on pourra
voir quel genre de sportif mardi
prochain du côté de du golf de de La
Couarde alors je peux déjà vous annoncer
les parrains marenes donc parmi les
parrains il y aura Laurent Blanc et
Antoine camboiré parmi les marenes Laura
flesselle et Luce de cosse mais il y a
de d'autres grands noms il y a 24
disciplines à ce jour
représenté voilà donc c'est rendez-vous
10h à peu près mardi prochain alors
voilà mardi 21 mai accueil à 10h pour un
brunch et puis se retrouve il y a la
compétition de golf qui démarre à 13h
les ateliers d'enfants à 15h et tout ce
petit monde se réunit autour de concours
peting spécial Roland Garos à
18h30 avec la remise des prix et la fête
en ultime et la récolte des fonds
officiel et c'est notre président de la
fé des tennis de Roland Garros qui
remettra le trophée des champions voilà
et c'est pas trop dur de s'inscrire
justement parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'associations beaucoup de galas c'est
ça doit être compliqué de de de survivre
entre guillemets avec ce contexte
économique je dirais à la fois très
difficile mais dans la vie il faut être
spécifique et unique sincèrement quand
quand j'appelle pour te break il y a il
y a un espèce d'amour filial il y a une
solidarité il y a une vrai auourd'i
justementment entre les différents
athlètes c'est connu aujourd'hui
sincèrement oui t break c'est alors non
seulement c'est connu mais c'est en plus
euh il y a une espèce de cation de
crédibilité et ça j'y tiens on rigole on
est souriant mais il y a des choses avec
lesquelles on rigole pas le le la tenue
des comptes on la transparence de là où
va l'argent des dons on montre aux
sportifs également on les emmène sur le
terrain sur ce qui est fait et il y a un
suivi au quotidien et je pense que voilà
c'est c'est comme je vous le dis c'est
les années qui payent au au bout du
compte les gens ils vont les yeux fermés
c'est maintenant les sportifs qui
amènent d'autres champions et ça c'est
formidable il faut savoir aussi que
Véronique fait un travail magnifique
parce que l'association fonctionne avec
0 € deond de fonctionnement donc c'est
un gros travail et nous on ne peut que
l'apporter notre soutien et voilà c'est
pourquoi nous sommes là aujourd'hui
bravo au champion bravo à
l'organisatrice également sport
solidaire voilà une belle opération nous
allons passer au premier championnat de
France de de cross triathlon qui av lieu
ce weekend du côté de Versailles un
titre historique évidemment une
compétition inédite bien plus exigeante
en fait que le triathlon classique et
qui a attiré l'élite française et il
fallait être costaud pour s'imposer
image de Michael Jarry natation course à
pied où la route laisse la place aux
forêts au chemin et les vélos profilés
au VTT vous êtes au premier championnat
de France de cross triathlon il faut
faire attention au coup de pompe après
le passage à vélo en VTT on ne peut pas
se cacher dans les roues comme les
coureurs peuvent le faire sur route
derrière la course devient vite
cassepatte comme on dit dans le pleoton
comparé au type de triathlon que je fais
Coupe d'Europe ou Grand Prix élite c'est
un peu plus dur parce que là on est en
VTT on est toujours en prise ça demande
de toujours toujours relancer toujours
pédaler et musculairement on se repose
jamais en VTT quasiment jamais et
ensuite quand on enchaîne sur du du
trail de chemin du chemin ou de l'herbe
là faut quand même faut quand même des
cuisses comparé à du tout plat sur la
route c'est vrai que c'est quand même
plus dur le VTT justement le champion de
France brise de Bor l'a mal encaissé
sorti en tête de l'au il pose le vélo
avec une minute de retard sur le
Monégasque Nicolas Fernandez mais au
prix d'une remontée à pied phénoménale
le médaillé de bronze au Championnat
d'Europe 2012 s'impose finalement en
1h31 chez les vétérans le versaillais
Olivier Constantin a conquis ce premier
titre historique je suis très très
content de de ma course çaétait je
voulais faire le trou en natation parce
que je savais qu'il y avait des vétérans
très costaud en N vélo j'ai tout donné
dans le premier tour à vélo pour me
mettre à l'abri et après j'ai essayé de
gérer en course à pied et je suis très
sa grâce à leur performance d'ensemble
les Versaillais remportent le titre par
équipe et évidemment pour un triathlon
du roi le nouveau champion prend place
sur son trône une couronne pour
l'histoire du triathlon
français